Eu preciso te contar uma coisa que tá
sacudindo o mundo da saúde agora em 2025
e que pode mudar completamente a forma
como você enxerga o jejum intermitente,
tão famoso, né? Milhões de pessoas fazem
jejum achando que estão otimizando tudo,
mas estudos recentes estão mostrando que
pode ter um preço escondido nisso tudo.
Esse preço mora bem ali no seu
intestino, na sua microbiota. Será que
ao tentar melhorar um lado você está
prejudicando o outro? Fica comigo porque
o que eu vou te revelar aqui pode fazer
você repensar sobre a sua estratégia de
jejum. Antes de mais nada, vamos
contextualizar essa história toda. O
jejum intermitente virou praticamente
uma religião nos últimos anos, não é
mesmo? Todo mundo fazendo 16, 18, alguns
até esticando para 24 ou mais. E olha,
tem fundamento nisso sim.
A gente sabe que o jejum traz benefícios
metabólicos importantes, ajuda na
altofagia, melhorar a sensibilidade
insulina, pode auxiliar na perda de
peso, mas aqui tá o pulo do gato que
muita gente não está sacando. Enquanto
você está focado nesses ganhos todos,
algo está acontecendo lá embaixo no seu
intestino com aquele exército de bilhões
ou trilhões de bactérias que moram em
você. Deixa eu te explicar uma coisa
fundamental. Sua microbiota intestinal
não é só um monte de bichinhos morando
de favor no seu corpo. Ela é tipo um
órgão extra, sabe? Essas bactérias
produzem vitaminas, regulam seu sistema
imune, fabricam neurotransmissores,
controlam inflamação, influenciam o seu
humor e até sua capacidade de emagrecer
ou engordar. É uma fábrica metabólica
gigantesca, trabalhando 24 horas por
dia. E adivinha o que que essas
bactérias precisam para viver bem?
comida, fibras, polifenóis, amido
resistente, prebióticos. E quando você
jejua por períodos muito longos, você tá
literalmente cortando o fornecimento de
alimento para esse exército microbiano.
Agora vamos ao que a ciência está
mostrando de novo. Estudos publicados
2024, início de 2025, principalmente em
revistas como Frontiers e Nutrition e
Nature Communications, começaram a
investigar de forma mais profunda o que
acontece com a composição bacteriana
durante jej prolongados. E olha, não é
simples. A história não é preto no
branco. O que os pesquisadores
observaram é que o jejum intermitente
realmente modula a microbiota, mas os
efeitos dependem de vários fatores,
especialmente a duração do jejum e o que
você come durante a janela alimentar. Eu
vou te dar um exemplo prático. Uma
revisão sistemática de 2024 publicada na
Frontiers e Nutrition analisou diversos
estudos inumanos sobre jejum
intermitente e chegou a algumas
conclusões importantes. Eles perceberam
que quando as pessoas jejuam, certas
bactérias aumentam, outras diminuem. Por
exemplo, a querermânciafila, aquela
bactéria que todo mundo da abordagem
funcional adora falar, que está
associado à saúde metabólica. Ela
aumenta durante o jejum e parece ótimo,
não é? Mas aqui vem o detalhe que poucos
te contam. A querermância é uma bactéria
degradadora de muscina. Ela se alimenta
de camada de muco que protege o seu
intestino. Pensa comigo, durante o
jejum, quando não tem comida chegando,
principalmente fibras e prebióticos, o
que essas bactérias vão fazer? Então
elas precisam sobreviver, então elas
começam a se alimentar do que está
disponível e o que está disponível é a
sua camada protetora de muco intestinal.
Um estudo de 2019 na PMC mostrou
exatamente isso. Durante jejuns
prolongados, bactérias com alta
atividade proteítica aumentam e começam
a degradar componentes do próprio
hospedeiro, incluindo células descamadas
e muscinas. É como se suas bactérias
começassem a comer seu próprio
revestimento intestinal quando ficam com
fome. E tem mais estudos sobre jejum
Ramadã, aquele jejum de aproximadamente
17 horas por dia durante o mês,
mostraram alterações interessantes e
controversas. Pesquisas publicadas em
2023 na Frontiers em Microbiology
identificaram que ao final do período de
jejum houve um aumento significativo de
proteactérias.
E olha, isso não é uma boa notícia.
Proteobactérias, especialmente a classe
gama proteobactéria, são consideradas
marcadoras de disbiose, aquele
desequilíbrio microbiano que a gente
tanto quer evitar. Essas bactérias
produzem lipopolissacarídeos,
endotoxinas inflamatórias que podem
vazar pela barreira intestinal e causar
inflamação sistêmica. No mesmo estudo,
eles observaram aumento de esquericha e
chiguela, que são bactérias
potencialmente patogênicas. Ao mesmo
tempo, houve diminuição de bactérias
benéficas, como bláa, coprococos, doreia
e outras da família lacnospirácia,
que são produtoras de butirato, aquele
ácido grasso de cadeia curta que nutre
as células do seu cumon e tem
propriedades inflamatórias potentes.
Agora, antes de você entrar em pânico e
abandone o jejum completamente, deixe
mostrar o outro lado da moeda, porque
tem estudos mostrando benefícios também.
Uma pesquisa publicada na Nature
Communications em 2024 comparou jejum
intermitente com proteína otimizada
versus restrição calórica contínua. O
grupo do jejum intermitente mostrou
melhor diversidade microbiana, aumento
de bactérias da família cristencenelace
associadas com menor adiposidade
visceral e melhoram sintomas
gastrointestinais.
Eles também tiveram aumento de
metabólitos favoráveis à oxidação de
gordura. Outros estudos mostraram
aumento de lactobacíos e bifobactérium,
aquelas bactérias probióticas que todo
mundo conhece, além do fecálio bactério
pronitse, uma das estrelas
antifamatórias do intestino.
Tem evidência de que jejuns moderados,
tipo aqueles de 16 por8 que virou
padrão, podem aumentar a diversidade
alfa, que é basicamente ter mais tipos
diferentes de bactérias no seu
intestino. E isso geralmente é sinal de
um ecossistema saudável. Então, qual é a
verdade afinal? A resposta na sutileza,
como sempre, o que os dados mais
recentes sugerem é que não é o jejum em
si que é vilão ou herói. É como você faz
um jejum. Deixa de explicar os pontos
críticos que estão emergindo da
literatura científica. Primeiro ponto,
duração importa demais. Jejuns de 12 a
16 horas parece ser a zona segura onde
você pega os benefícios metabólicos sem
causar estresse excessivo na microbiota.
Quando você faz mais, tipo, passa de 18,
20 horas, especialmente se faz isso
diariamente, o risco de shift negativo
aumenta. Estudos em camundongos de 2020
mostraram que 16 horas de jejum
aumentaram a querermância e diminuíram a
listips, mas esses efeitos apareceram
quando o jejum cessou. Interessante, né?
Isso sugere que o efeito não é
permanente e que seu microbioma tem
resiliência. Segundo ponto, o que você
come na janela alimentar é absolutamente
determinante. Se você quebra o jejum com
carboidratos afinados, açúcar e proteína
sem fibras, você está perdendo a
oportunidade de nutrir adequadamente
suas bactérias benéficas. A correlação
negativa entre consumo de vegetais e
cetas bactérias patogênicas foi
documentada em múltiplos estudos: fibras
diversas, amido resistente, polifenóis.
Esses são os nutrientes que suas
bactérias precisam durante a janela
alimentar para compensar o período sem
comida. Terceiro ponto, individualidade
biológica. Seu microbioma é único, como
uma impressão digital. Dois estudos de
2024 mostraram que a resposta ao jejum
varia enormemente, dependendo da
composição microbiana de base, do
fenótipo metabólico, da idade e até do
estilo de vida. Não existe receita
universal. O que funciona para seu
vizinho pode não funcionar para você.
Quarto ponto, a questão temporal. Vários
estudos mostram que as alterações
microbianas durante o jejum podem ser
transitórias.
Um trabalho interessante mostrou que
muitas das mudanças microbiônias
observadas durante o Ramadã
desapareceram um mês após o término de
jejum. Isso levanta uma questão. Será
que estamos causando oscilações
constantes sem estabelecer um novo
equilíbrio saudável? E aqui que vem um
achado que me deixou particularmente
atento. Estudos de jejum prolongado,
tipo aqueles de 10 dias no método
Bushinger, mostraram uma inversão da
razão firmicutes bacterioidetes com
grande aumento de bacterioidetes. Esses
bacterioes aumentados são justamente
aqueles com alta atividade proteítica,
capazes de degradar proteínas e muscinas
do hospedeiro. Então, os pesquisadores
encontraram correlação entre o aumento
de bacterioidetes e níveis fecais de
aminoácid ramificada, sugerindo que em
ausência de nutrientes dietéticos, a
microbiota passou a usar compostos
derivados do hospedeiro como fonte de
energia. Então, vamos falar prático
agora. Como você usa essas informações
para otimizar o seu jejum sem destruir a
sua microbiota? Primeiro, se você está
fazendo jejunitente, considere manter
janelas de 12 a 16 horas como padrão.
Jejuns mais longos. Reserve para
situações ocasionais, não diariamente.
Segundo, isso é crucial. Foque
intensamente na qualidade da sua
alimentação durante a janela alimentar.
Você precisa de fibras diversas, no
mínimo 30 g por dia, de fontes variadas,
vegetais, frutas, legumes, grãos
integrais, tubérculos. Terceiro,
considere suplementação estratégica.
Prebióticos como inulina,
frutoossacarídeos,
galactoigossacarídeos
podem ajudar a nutrir suas bactérias
benéficas. Polifenóis de fontes como chá
verde, cacau, frutas vermelhas também
são alimento para microbioma. Quarto,
monitore sinais de disbiose. Se você
começar a ter mais gases, de extensão,
alteração no padrão intestinal, queda de
energia, isso pode ser sinal de que o
seu microbioma não está feliz com o
protocolo atual. Quinto, cicle os
protocolos. Não faça o mesmo jejum
internamente. Alterem períodos de jejum
de 16 por8 com período de alimentação
mais frequente e mais controlada. Dê
tempo se o microbioma se recalibrar.
E sexto, considere exames. Uma análise
de microbioma pode te dar insight sobre
como seu ecossistema intestinal está
respondendo ao jejum. Deixa eu te contar
sobre um conceito que está emergindo na
literatura mais avançada, o conceito de
flexibilidade metabólica microbiana. Seu
microbioma ideal não é aquele que tem
sempre as mesmas espécies em abundância
fixa, é aquele que consegue se adaptar a
diferentes estados nutricionais sem
perder funcionalidade. É como um músculo
que fica forte com exercício adequado,
mas saturofia com excesso ou falta de
uso. O jejum pode ser o exercício que
treina o seu microbioma para essa
flexibilidade, mas só se for feito com
inteligência. E olha, tem um aspecto
temporal que a maioria das pessoas
ignora. Isso nos mostram que as
bactérias do seu intestino também têm
ritmo circadiano. Elas oscilam em
composição e atividade ao longo de 24
horas. Quando você come em horários
errados, faz jejuns que desrespeitam
totalmente esses ritmos, você pode estar
causando uma desupção cicadiana,
microbiana. Alguns pesquisadores sugerem
que alinhar um jejum com ciclo luz
escuro natural, tipo parar de comer ao
entardecer e jejuar até amhã seguinte,
pode ser mais harmonioso com a biologia
tanto do hospedeiro quanto das
bactérias. Outro ponto que está sendo
investigado agora em 2025 é a produção
de metabólitos durante o jejum.
Bactérias como paraabacterioides
deçones e bacterioides teta atomicron
aumentam durante o jejum intermitente e
produzem suxinato e gaba, compostos que
parecem mediar alguns dos efeitos
benéficos do jejum metabolismo e na
saúde cardiovascular. Então não é só
sobre ter ou não ter certas bactérias, é
sobre o que essas bactérias estão
produzindo metabolicamente. Tem também a
questão da mucosa intestinal. Quando
você jejua, não é só a microbiota que
muda. A própria estrutura intestinal
passa por adaptações. Estudos animais
mostram que o intestino pode sofrer
alterações morfológicas durante jejos
prolongados. A camada de muco pode ficar
mais fina em algumas regiões. As
vilosidades intestinais podem se
remodelar. Isso tudo faz parte de uma
resposta adaptativa, mas precisa ser
temporário, não permanente. E aqui vai
uma verdade conveniente. A maioria dos
estudos sobre jejum e microbiota são de
curta duração. A gente tem muitos dados
sobre o que tá acontecendo em 4 semanas,
8 semanas, talvez 12 semanas, mais e
após anos fazendo o mesmo protocolo de
jejum. Ninguém sabe ao certo ainda. Os
estudos de longo prazo simplesmente não
existem em número suficiente. Então,
quando alguém te vende um jejum com uma
solução definitiva eterna, tem que ligar
o sinal de alerta. Olha, eu vou ser bem
direto com você. O jejum intermitente
não é vilão nem herói, é uma ferramenta.
Como qualquer ferramenta pode construir
ou destruir, dependendo de como você
usa. Se você faz jejuns moderados, nutre
adequadamente seu microbioma durante a
janela alimentar, respeita os sinais do
seu corpo e cicla protocolos, as
evidências sugerem que você pode colher
benefícios tanto metabólicos quanto
microbianos. Mas se você está fazendo
jejuns extremos diariamente, comendo
porcaria na janela alimentar, ignorando
sintomas de disbiose, você pode estar
sim prejudicando o seu ecossistema
intestinal a longo prazo. A mensagem que
a ciência de 2024, 2025 está trazendo é
de personalização e cautela inteligente.
Não existe protocolo universal. Seu
microbioma é único, é seu. E respond.
O caminho não é copiar o que funciona
por influência de internet. é entender
os princípios, aplicar com sensatez,
monitorar resultados e ajustar conforme
necessário. E lembra, a diversidade
microbiana geralmente se correlaciona
com a saúde. Se o seu protocolo de jejum
está levando a monotonia microbiana, com
poucas espécies dominando, isso é sinal
vermelho. Para fechar, deixa eu te dar
uma perspectiva prática. Se você quer
fazer jejunto emitente, preservando e
até melhorando sua microbiota, comece
devagar, gradual. Não pule comer a cada
3 horas para jejum de 20 horas. Comece
com 12, depois 14. Veja como seu corpo e
seus sintomas digestivos respondem.
Invista pesar na qualidade alimentar da
janela. Fibras, fibras e mais fibras.
Diversidade. Considere adicionar
alimentos fermentados, kefir, chucrute,
quinchi, que trazem bactérias vivas e
também substratos fermentáveis. Use
polifenol estrategicamente. E mais
importante, escute seu corpo. Se algo
não está certo, ajuste. Não seja escravo
de protocolo nenhum. O protócolo tem que
servir você e não o contrário.
Agora é o momento de você sair do vídeo
se você gosta de ficar no superficial.
Eu vou te contar uma verdade
conveniente. O YouTube e o Conselho de
Medicina me limitam. Aqui eu preciso
simplificar, censurar dosagens, omitir
protocolos controversos. Na comunidade
fechada não tem esse filtro. Eu
compartilho os exatos protocolos que eu
uso na minha clínica. Casos de reversão
que parecem possíveis, combinações offel
que funcionam, fornecedores confiáveis,
interpretação avançada de exames. É
basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários. Então, temos
lives semanais respondendo perguntas,
PDF com 47 protocolos exclusivos, grupo
no WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão
funcional real, sem simplificação para
as massas, clique em seja membro. Não é
para curiosos, é para quem quer
resultados. Yeah.